hello there
perhaps your academic social media
exploded too
or maybe you are still unaware of the
news
but it's true a pure transformer beats
the state-of-the-art in image
recognition
yes you heard right images vision the
realm dominated for
centuries by the convolutional neural
networks or short cnns
in this video we will explain how the
transformer was able to beat the cnn on
its own image
battleground and we will discuss whether
the rise of the transformer will
really mean the extinction of cnns
so it happened the transformers which we
explained in a previous video linked
below
took over the field of natural language
processing during the last couple of
years
it recently moved on to integrate vision
and language in multi-modal transformer
architectures find the explanation link
below
now after some cnn transformer hybrid
attempts
it happened the pure vision transformer
is the new state of the art
and this ruins the cnn fascination of
miss coffee bean
or really but how does the transformer
do it
well by doing better than cnn's for
start
a convolutional neural network uses
kernels to aggregate
very local information in each layer
which
then is passed to the next layer that
aggregates
again local information but now with a
larger
field of view because it looks at
information that was already
aggregated by the first layer
the take home message here is that cnns
start to look very locally and their
receptive field becomes more global in
each layer
and after quite some training time
but the vision transformer presented in
this very anonymous
paper succeeds at having a large field
of view from the very beginning
it overcomes the limitations of cnns
that look very narrowly at first
limitations which help where there's not
much training data but about this later
the transformer looks at the image by
taking the input image and splitting it
into
patches of by 16 pixels
these patches are then flattened by a
linear transformation
a matrix so that they become vectors
then everything else what happens we
know already from the language
transformer because
the same thing is applied here the
vector of each patch gets positional
embeddings and the usual transformer is
then used to predict what the image
might represent
done this was the method why does it do
better than cnns
because the anonymous authors can train
on an
awful lot of training data for an awful
lot of tpu days
that's something all anonymous authors
can do
or not the transformer
is unlike the cnn very data hungry
especially because it has the freedom to
look everywhere onto the image from
the start in other words it is
very unfocused at first and it needs
huge data
amounts to learn how to focus and what
to focus its attention on
to make the right predictions on many
amounts of data the transformer can find
very original and unexpected ways to
look
at the data because there's no element
in the architecture that tells the model
how to do that
exactly the cnn however
is focused from the beginning by the
convolutions towards a local view
the given focus patterns can be a
limitation
but we can also spare a lot of training
data on this
because we do not have to teach the
model how to focus
only what to focus so
will transformers replace cnns
for heavyweight state-of-the-art winners
benchmark
crushing gpu-intensive data-hungry
energy-consuming environmental
unfriendly kind of ai
yes most probably yeah possibly
for lightweight machine learning in
production for computational and energy
economic settings for
green ai cnns and even
far more classical approaches will still
be out there
at least for a while the paper discussed
here
is at iclear still under double blind
review
we will update the video description
with the full paper information
after the authors have been revealed
until then
try to figure out yourself who the
authors might be
but do not tell the paper's reviewers
otherwise you might ruin the double
blind peer review
or was the whole setting ruined already
okay bye
[Music]
you